[Musik]
mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren und ich bin 22 jahre alt
allerdings war auch ich einmal 110 jahre
als eher kleine abwechslung und da habe
ich mir fürs heutige video mal überlegt
freunde machen wir doch heute einfach
mal 24 stunden als kind unterwegs für
mich war es früher ein absolutes
highlight wenn ich zum frühstück nicht
irgendwo essen musste was meine mutter
seit zwei wochen neben dem gefrierfach
hat sondern wenn ich etwas frühstücken
durfte das richtig viel zucker
beinhaltete kriegen meine damen und
herren werden wir zum bäcker gehen und
ich werde mir dort einen donut kaufen
gehen wir sind jetzt im supermarkt
angekommen und hier vorne den donau
werde ich mir gönnen darf ich glaube er
hatte schon freuen uns war es heute so
richtig richtig mittel haft rechnerisch
windiges wetter und was hat man als kind
gemacht wenn eklat windiges drittel
gespielt wurde
dann ist ins schwimmbad gefahren
deswegen zum schwimmbad
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt werde ich mit
schwimmfreunde und auch ich als
zehnjährige auf die regeln geben und
zwar dass man im grunde keine schuhe
trägt immer an die regeln halten
nachdem ihr ein schwimmbad bahn
[Musik]
richtiges 19-jährigen schöne fischen
nuggets und tanz
[Musik]
jetzt auch gegessen und das war sehr
lecker und jetzt darf ich mir einen
comic kaufen wir haben hier nur so doofe
erwachsenen bücher und jungen nur so was
für kleine gehe ich jetzt einfach nach
hause spielt luca hast du doch was
gefunden ja falls kein komiker um den
schoko fonds gekauft lecker macht ihn
besonders gern ich hatte eigentlich
überlegt dass man jetzt ganz gut auf den
spielplatz gehen könnte weil keine
ahnung als zehnjähriger ist man glaube
ich ganz gerne spielt als er gegangen
aber darauf wirklich echt so voll
komplett bescheuert weltuntergang
regensturm wind wetter ist gucke ich
jetzt fernsehen madagaskar habe ich als
kind echt sehr gern geguckt also was ich
mir als kanisch die gerne gespielt haben
war kuno deswegen müssen wir jetzt immer
die karten und spinde rolle und wir
sehen wer der gewinner ist also nee ich
ein paar sekunden später verloren
das wetter ist jetzt wieder besser
geworden
das heißt ich spielen gehen da gehe ich
jetzt doch dann war gleich hoch
man jetzt gerade aus um noch ein spiel
spielen dass ein bisschen nicht so
windig war haben wir gedacht wir gehen
jetzt nochmal aufgestanden weil ich bin
ja auch gerade spielt gleiches war am
strand gespielt habe sitzen jetzt noch
irgendwer muss auf und ich trinke
natürlich einen körper auf
wenn jähriger junge bin heute meine
damen und herren backen wikis sind
eigentlich diese puppen hier zum abend
ist und wenn man es als zehnjähriger
natürlich kinder schnitzel mit pommes
und ketchup mayo k was machst du jetzt
wir sind jetzt zu hause angekommen dass
ich als zehnjähriges kind spiel jetzt
wieder nur hunde uno weil ich muss ja
noch nicht schlafen gehen weil ich dafür
noch ein bisschen länger wach bleiben
dabei ist natürlich wieder meine show
cobox ist übrigens kein placement aber
ich habe die zum beispiel ein
zehnjähriges kind über das gern
vergessen und ich nach cola trinken auf
die bank bringen
nur dann kannst du nicht schlafen +2
ich liege jetzt auch im bett meine damen
und herren und macht man gerne als sie
ihr dann will ich schlafen geben sondern
spielt noch irgendwie was und bei mir
war es so ich habe einmal mein lieblings
youtuber geschaut nämlich kontrakte
genau an der stelle wird jetzt
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren ich habe mir einfach mal gedacht
hey wieso eigentlich ein tag aus wenn
man ein kind war deswegen hab ich mir
gedacht mach' ich heute schon nur sachen
die man gerne als kind gemacht hat und
zwar beispielsweise schwimmen gehen oder
sich irgendwie wieder schnitzel kaufen
kinder schnitzen oder irgendwie auf dem
spielplatz gehen oder keine ahnung was
lange wach bleiben cola trinken aber auf
jeden fall hier so schlaff heute wird
euch das video hier gefallen hat das
gerne mal einen leid da was soll ich
vielleicht als hochladen worauf habe die
box schreibt vor und in die kommentare
und jetzt kommt das auto glas wasser zu
ihr vom video das war es jetzt hier vom
video hier können
jetzt hier bei den kanal abonnieren oder
hier unten meinen job aus schenkungen
jetzt findet ihr zwei andere videos und
managen abonnent zeit könnt ihr auf die
glocke klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]